I told you just two days ago that
coronavirus is continuing to ravage in
particular some parts of the country but
meanwhile confusingly the country is
opening more and more particularly the
parts of the country that are having the
case and death problems we have a
planned Tulsa Oklahoma Trump rally with
thousands of people on Saturday dr.
Anthony Fauci has already recommended
against going to such a rally rally
goers in fact have to sign a waiver for
coronavirus contagion if they want
tickets to this Donald Trump rally but
we now have several more days of data
and the corona virus pandemic in some
particular states is spiking so quickly
so quickly and so aggressively that the
numbers almost seem fake but they are
not fake and what I mean is when you
look at these case graphs that I'm going
to show you we are more than three
months into this pandemic it's hard to
believe that some states are managing
the pandemic so poorly that we are now
getting these spikes like these states
are nowhere near the peaks that some
states reached in early to mid April
looking at Texas for example I already
told you days ago that cases were
spiking in Texas that was nothing
compared to what we are now seeing a
record four thousand cases in one day in
Texas yesterday these are unconscionable
numbers sticking with this part of the
country
Arizona is quickly becoming the hot spot
in terms of case growth rate in the
United States also with a record 2400
cases yesterday when you look at these
charts they're downright dystopian spoke
to a friend in Arizona again everybody's
just acting like nothing's going on he
says stores are open people packed
together nobody's wearing masks just
like almost no mitigation going on at
all Florida very similar curve have a
lot of friends in Florida very worried
and again yesterday the worst day in
Florida since all of this started also
thousands of new cases so I really need
people to understand the content
next year we're months into this White
House coronavirus task force in place
for months
mitigation testing PPE stay at home
orders wear masks endure months and
months and months and yesterday was the
worst day since the start of this in
Texas Florida and Arizona now it's not
just red states as I've mentioned
California which was an early hotspot
it's still having having problems
they've not exactly flattened the curve
but even the growth rates in California
are not the erratic numbers that we are
seeing in some other places now
meanwhile I continue to be really glad
that things are going well in some
places I'm not saying this to brag it's
just luck that I mean I guess it's not
luck I live in Massachusetts obviously
partially I live here because my family
moved here partially I live in
Massachusetts because I prefer the
politics of Massachusetts to those of
some of these other states the case
curve here just falling off a cliff if
you're watching Connecticut doing really
well lots of states are doing very well
and will see as they start to open
whether that changes so the point here
is mitigation works the cases and the
deaths respond to what people are
actually doing the weather does not seem
to be stopping the spread in warmer
states and as the summer comes and the
Trump administration is just pretending
that it's over things are actually so
bad right now in some states that this
conversation about wave two is
essentially irrelevant in the sense that
there's not going to be a dip it it
seems as though you know we had this
idea wave one would be dying off by late
April early May we might have almost no
new cases by June 1st there were models
that said by June 1 there will be almost
no new cases we've got 20,000 new cases
a day in some of these states there
won't be a wave to because wave 1 will
never end
wave 2 was supposed to start you know
maybe September mid September we are now
looking at at least in some states that
have not even hit their peaks just a
continued sustained pandemic through the
end of the year if nothing changes the
way Texas is looking Florida Arizona
it's very difficult to imagine with
cases spiking to where they are now that
there actually will be a dip that we
could call a pause between waves we
could just have a six or eight or nine
month wave until hopefully there is an
effective treatment and a vaccine and
half the country seems to be pretending
that everything is fine now in terms of
you know what's safe in different places
I posted a picture of myself in
Massachusetts over the weekend sitting
outdoors at a cafe it felt safe given
the the numbers here we're down to only
you know 100 we had only 58 new cases a
couple days ago about 150 a day under
200 people now left in the ICU in the
entire state I ordered online
I grabbed my coffee and bagel didn't you
know interact with anybody sat outside
at a table nobody around me when I leave
I flip a piece of paper on the table
that goes from green to red so other
people know not to sit there waitstaff
come over and and clean it it seems safe
I mean the the the outdoor contagion is
primarily when people are doing
obviously stupid things crowding
together at you know on out of hiking
trail or something like that it seems
like that is relatively safe what we're
seeing in other states where it's
indoors no masks people on top of each
other of course that's going to lead to
spread so you know we talked about the
80/20 rule we talked about 80 80 percent
of people are incompetent at whatever
they're doing most of the rules about
even outdoors you should look at wearing
a mask we only need to be doing that
because of the small portion of people
that are just doing stupid things unless
you tell them wear a mask outdoors and
that is something that we can't ignore
when we look at state leadership on down
that's a big part of why some of these
states are having such major problems